voyez c'est ça c'est à dire que là vous
êtes à fort de france je crois que tout
le monde peut se rendre compte
maria est en train d'arriver sur fort de
france mais a déjà effectivement touché
la martinique par la côte atlantique
les vents seront les vents les plus
forts ce 200 km heure seront un petit
peu plus loin le cyclone ayant fait une
légère inflexion et nous avons déjà
quelques éléments de dégâts puisque ce
sont désormais 25 mille foyers qui sont
privées d'électricité donc le chiffre a
augmenté depuis tout à l'heure
également nous avons une petite
préoccupations sur le débordement du
galion à gros morne
nous avons une quarantaine
d'interventions des sapeurs-pompiers
forte heureusement pas très grave on
signale une personne qui est tombé d'un
toit
et puis nous avons quelques
interrogations sur des usines
d'approvisionnement en eau qui sont
ensablés et qui donc désormais ne vont
peut-être plus pouvoir délivrer d'eau
potable ça c'est chaque commune qui est
en train de s'informer
donc nous referons je pense dans les
prochaines heures le dieu pour que la
population sache exactement si l'eau
potable peut être consommée ou pas ce
que je voudrais dire c'est que nous
sommes actuellement sur les épisodes
cycloniques je crois que la population
de la martinique les martiniquais les
martiniquaises peuvent se rendent compte
petit à petit que le cyclone est en
train de nous deux nous concerne et donc
qu'il convient vraiment de rester
prudent de ne pas sortir nous sommes
toujours pour le moment sur
le niveau d alerte violer c'est à dire
que chacun doit rester chez soi il s'est
très légèrement écartés un tout petit
peu de la martinique ce qui fait que les
vents les plus violents ce qui sans ce
qu'on appelle le mur de l'oeil du
cyclone ne toucheront pas la martinique
mais enfin on a quand même des rafales à
180 km/heure sur le nord atlantique de
la martinique donc c'est quand même des
ventes très très sérieux on est on est
je le rappelle quand même turin c'est
claudie majeurs c'est-à-dire catégorie 3
donc il ya un vrai danger à sortir c'est
franck robine
on vous retrouve tout à leur ouïe jeu